this club does not say it okay okay cus
hi I'm like Cher I go by going now I
don't know if you've ever hosted a talk
show but I know you're super funny I've
watched so many so much of your work and
stuff but I didn't know your last name
totally acceptable and then I was like
it's cool it'll be on the card all it
says is hard G I'm here with Gillian
Jacobs I think you're really great on
vine really yes what's your favorite of
my vines
I love the one where you're just goofing
on the community side oh those are good
ones neither of us have our phone no
it's rude to bring your phone to an
interview speak you can leave on my end
looks like I'm toasting your head haha I
can't work we found a good swatter
tonight with me drinking your eggs we
don't need our phones to make a vine
let's just do something for six seconds
and lupine okay great
hey girls hey pip hey girls hey Pete
yeah hey girls hey Pete I guess it's
better with the app here are some of the
questions I was going on okay what kind
of shampoo do you use what kind of
shampoo he is Kerastase in the green
bottle Kerastase in the green bottle
yeah there's different colors of
Kerastase I'm aware of the color scheme
with Kerastase
what color of Kerastase do you use look
flamingo pink alright there is a pink
one you got away with that that time in
the shower bar soap or body wash can I
guess yeah let's play what I call the
Senate game okay you have a loofah you
don't use it you have a exfoliating bar
of soap meaning it's like you don't
remember where you got it but it's like
light beige and it has little flecks why
am i gross in your imagination
there's also a human body decomposing in
the tub you're finally right about
something uh
Body Wash V wash body wash into a loof
know what those are gross how do you
clean a loofah how long do you have a
loofah for before you throw it out I
have a tiny loofah that I clean the
loofah here's a Mary Kelly right yeah
George Clooney the clean bag The
Descendants George Clooney up in the air
Clooney and I do mean the movie up in
the air not gravity or one fine day
clearly you know what I'm gonna change
that cuz I haven't seen one time I've
seen one fine day with Michelle Pfeiffer
is it where Macaulay Culkin gets stung
by bees and dies not to my girlie you
know that kill descendants Clooney cuz
he's real sad yeah up in the air
cuz he's it's he's like that's what he's
that's his whole vibe in that movie yeah
you marry one fine day what a sweet
movie I agree I love that you should see
that movie from Iran I'm gonna change
one fine day to gravity because I
haven't seen one fine day okay
I'm going to gravity Clooney cuz he
deserves it he earned it for floating
around in a scary place and not losing
his cool okay up in the air I'm also
gonna
is because he's got that American
Express we're going to do it in a tiny
airport airplane bathroom I like my
head's on the sink mmm blind picture and
then descendants Clooney I'm gonna
because he seemed so sad
no one should do that sad near roasting
pigs and lotus flowers likewise I'm
gonna lotus ya know in Japan
basically you just want to George
Clooney the clean bag yeah that reminds
me I brought you some gifts no yes I did
I'm so excited mm-hmm
I brought you some nail polish finally
an excuse you brought me a little a
little bowtie I know it's not a bowtie
it's a hair clip okay connect with um
you what are we not the best friend
that's great yeah don't do it wrong
guess you've ever been oh my god you're
the prettiest you've ever ever been
who's just so first I want to do that
thing where girls are about to cry and
they fan their eyes it works and look up
keep the tears in Gillian how do you
feel about hugging your new friend great
it's me oh yeah
you